you never knew what was going to happen
you never knew which protesters are
gonna show up there were four or five
events a day he was going all over the
place
it was absolutely exhausting but it was
exciting he did tire out the journalists
a third of his age and been talking
about journalists sometimes in the early
20s struggling to keep up with this
presidential candidate on the doorstep
of 70 and he just had this amazing
energy that that's one of the reasons he
won I talked about that a little bit the
Sunday before Election Day he was in
seven states and these weren't states
grouped close together you know in New
England or something like that
these were states plumbing across the
country he just had more energy Hillary
Clinton I think relied on her surrogates
a lot more I'm not sure if her health
problems weighed into this but I think
the Clinton campaign felt they had their
bases covered if they sent Bill Clinton
here and Barack Obama there and Joe
Biden there and Hillary would do one
event a day something like that and
again that didn't connect to voters the
fact that Trump was working so hard and
could speak off the cuff about where he
had just been and what he had heard
where he was and where he was going to
next that created a kind of immediate
intimacy again with with the people in
each place he went to and
it was fun at times to socialize with
people I don't socialize with other
journalists that often but no around
World Series games and things like that
we did that and there were some funny
things that happened on the press plane
there were some tense moments also there
are some very strict rules about what
you can report about what goes on inside
the press van or on the press plane and
I had a disagreement with the head of
the press pool basically about one of my
stories where I was reporting on a press
reaction to something Trump had said I
didn't quote anybody but it was evident
what the reaction was and I was told you
know I shouldn't do that and it was it
was his back and forth so a lot of
stories about what happened on the press
plane don't make it into the book for
that reason crash playing the press
banner off-the-record which i think is a
shame in a way because I think that
media narratives really are set among
journalists I think there's a
significant amount of cooperation
sometimes out of necessity people share
quotes if somebody missed something from
said somebody will fill it in so you
need to cooperate with each other but
there's also a shared worldview where an
idea coalesces inside the press about
the meaning of something Trump has said
or whether it was acceptable for him to
have said that and there's very little
dissent I would hear things that were
said all the time that I disagreed 100%
I could hear other people agreeing with
it and being an argumentative person
sometimes I would want to say hey I
disagree with that but when you're
surrounded by 40 or 50 people who are
more senior than you in most cases and
we've been doing this for longer it's
very hard to say hey I disagree with the
rest of you when you're all just
furiously typing anyway toward a
deadline you don't have energy for that
kind of argument so it would I think be
interesting to see inside what the press
is actually doing I think the public
would benefit from it I think the
journalists would benefit from it
because I think there is a herd
mentality that has developed in our
press corps and I think it would behoove
journalists to think themselves out of
it to find ways of looking at events and
understanding events that don't fall
into this established pattern right now
for example I think most of the media
sees itself as the opposition party you
know Steve banning in the White House
call them that but I think they started
seeing themselves as the opposition
party before he can go to name
and I think it's a mistake I think it's
a mistake obviously any press corps is
going to have somewhat of combative
relationship with any president because
the administration wants to get things
done and the media want to report on
what the administration is doing wrong
or not doing but I think the media has
taken a partisan stance that has
undermined its own ability to reach its
audience and ironically makes that
partisan effort harder to reach its
fulfillment if you're trying to convince
people to come around to your point of
view but you're undermining trust and
your own credibility you're gonna lose
the people you're trying to bring along
with you so I think there's some room
for a media reform or for journalists to
think about how they report on
presidential campaigns when they hear
ideas they don't like you know what
Breitbart we're a conservative website
but our method when we cover liberal
politicians or liberal events is usually
just to present them as they are our
audience does not need to be told what's
good and what's bad and what a liberal
politician says and the straight
delivery is often the most effective so
I went to cover Hillary Clinton's for
example last August speaking about the
alt rights it was basically an attack on
Breitbart news which she lumped in there
with you all right and she was giving
this speech to this audience and it was
just interesting to report exactly what
she said and and the reactions of the
crowd nobody in the crowd knew what the
alt-right was her campaign had chosen to
stage this in order to paint Trump as an
extremist and so forth but just simply
to report what she was saying was very
effective in telling our audience what
they needed to know first of all about
the facts about what she had said but
secondly about how out of touch she and
her campaign were with what was really
going on inside the campaign that this
wasn't some fringe movement but this was
a populist moment where Trump was
connecting to millions and millions and
millions of people who didn't get their
opinions from Twitter and didn't get
their opinions from obscure websites or
blogs but people who had been
experiencing some of the things Trump
was talking about in their everyday
lives that no other politician had
acknowledged so I think there's a lot to
be learned from the way the press cover
2016 I don't think that learning has
happened yet I think we're still seeing
journalists trapped in the same mode
but certainly I got along well with
those people who wanted to be friendly
people from left-wing outlets it really
is a question of temperament of
individual people and how polite people
are willing to be with one another
sometimes you'll find a conservative
journalists who I might agree with on
the issues who I don't get along with or
we don't belong with me and try to get
along with everybody it's not possible
all the time especially among
competitors but I think there's maybe a
next book to be written about the
lessons for the media of this campaign
and so far this young presidency Joe
Pollak how did you get to Breitbart
won't you back back okay it's very
interesting so well how far back do you
want to go I was very liberal in college
and shortly thereafter in fact I was
part of the College Democrats but they
were a little bit too centrist for my
taste I was much more in the radical
wing of the Democratic Party you know I
would have been a kind of Bernie Sanders
weird remoter
I grew up in the suburbs of Chicago very
little cool I went to public school as
well as Jewish religious school earlier
on but I went to Harvard College for
undergraduate and I began to change my
mind a little bit about halfway through
college I still thought of myself as on
the left but there were things that
began to bother me the most important
thing that bothered me was the hostility
to questions I used to go to a lot of
left-wing political events and lectures
and I used to ask questions and I was
often told that my question was based on
an inner incorrect assumption and that's
how they answered all the questions you
know if you had a question it was it was
because you didn't understand something
I went to conservative events and I
would ask challenging questions this is
as a liberal student and I never got
that reaction I would get an explanation
I would get a response and even though
the students around me didn't agree with
me I would never be shouted down or
anything like that so the
open-mindedness of conservatism on
campus attracted me a little bit but
really it was my time in South Africa I
spent seven years between college and
law school in South Africa first working
as a freelance journalist and working as
a speechwriter
and that really opened my eyes because I
saw him any of the left-wing policies
that I had strongly believed in just a
few years before being implemented and I
saw that they were actually destructive
in many cases they achieved the opposite
of what they had set out to accomplish I
still thought of myself as a Democrat
when I came back but after about six
months in the country and at law school
on campus I realized I wasn't so I
became a Republican became active in
Republican causes I volunteered on the
McCain campaign 2008 and I had this
infamous confrontation with Barney Frank
when he came to give a lecture at
Harvard and that went viral when YouTube
was still relatively young and I got a
call from Republicans back home in
Illinois who said we need someone to run
in this district would you consider
doing it and I said okay so I ran for
Congress in a very blue district on a
conservative platform and we lost badly
but the campaign was very successful we
had this conservative campaign that
raised almost 700,000 dollars and I'm
not self-financing in any way no student
loans and the whole deal it was just the
excitement of finally having a
conservative candidate to vote for that
brought out hundreds of volunteers and
donors from across the country and we
ran a tough energetic campaign and in
the course of that campaign I met Andrew
Breitbart
and he called me a candidate journalist
the reason he called me a candidate
journalist was I was doing my own
opposition research when I went to the
RNC and said what do you have on my
opponent they said well no one's ever
really run against her so we don't have
anything and we've never really tried
because it's such a liberal district we
just never put the resources into it so
I ran this opposition research campaign
and we uncovered things that didn't just
tell a story about my opponent but
really told the story about what was
going on in the Democratic Party because
she was deeply connected to Obama into
the political operation around Obama
particularly through her husband Robert
creamer who's a well-known Democratic
house key that's right jan Schakowsky
and her husband robert creamer and
creamer had trained obama's activists
and creamer was a community organizer
and
was in a way the mastermind behind a lot
of the policies Obama had implemented in
the first year or two of his presidency
and those links had never fully been
explored or uncovered so I broke a lot
of stories out of that I started writing
on Breitbart at the time it was big
government.com Breitbart comm hadn't
really become the news side of this
today and so Andrew and I developed a
friendship and then after the election
after I lost I sort of pitched the idea
to him of coming out to work in LA doing
legal work for the company because it
had started to grow company which had
started with one employee in Andrew
Breitbart spaceman was now half a dozen
employees and it was growing and it was
becoming a national media story or
national media organization and I think
I was employee number seven and I moved
out there and I was in-house counsel the
first six months I still have in-house
counsel responsibilities but then as the
company really started to expand Andrew
made me editor in chief and I was editor
in chief for two years including the
period when he died suddenly and we had
to hold the company together reboot as a
news organization and really start
breaking stories we had been a blog site
for the first few years of the web site
and that was good in terms of giving a
voice to conservatives and citizen
journalists but it wasn't good in terms
of competing with mainstream media and
not just competing with but replacing in
a sense at the front of the of the
breaking news pack and Andrews vision
was always to get into breaking news
24-hour news and to move into other
media so we now have radio on Sirius XM
we have our shows Breitbart news daily
and the Breitbart week weekend shows on
channel 125 unserious
so it's been amazing to see the company
grow it's now more than a hundred
employees and to come in when it was
still relatively young and be a part of
its success has been has been incredible
I think andrew would be proud of it I
think he would be fascinated by what's
going on today but I think he would have
anticipated a lot of it in a way Trump
was a candidate anticipated by Breitbart
even though he wasn't
a conservative in the way that Breitbart
was a conservative coming out of the
movement especially here we are at
Freedom Fest Andrew Breitbart really
tended toward the libertarian side in
many ways and Trump has some liberal
tendencies when it comes to social
issues but some of his policies are not
libertarian I'm sure people will be
talking a lot about that at this
conference they've been talking about it
already but Andrew understood that Trump
knew how the media worked and could
overcome the media and Andrew said in
2012 that because of the way Trump beats
the media Trump is going to be your
candidate one day if you don't watch out
in other words he was saying he's not a
conservative the way these other people
are conservatives but he's going to be
the candidate you get because he knows
how to fight and you guys don't and I
think Andrews early feelings about that
were were fulfilled and the reason many
Republicans voted for Trump even those
didn't like him was that he is a fighter
and he fights back against the people
that Republicans feel are really their
opponents which is less Democrats and
liberals and more the media Andrew
believed and I believe that given a
level playing field where the media
allows both sides equal time and equal
respect and equal coverage conservatives
will win most of those debates and so a
lot of the energy of the media is
devoted to marginalizing conservatives
marginalizing Republicans so that we
don't have the same chance to have our
point of view now the remedy for that is
not some kind of fairness doctrine where
everybody is forced to have equal access
or anything like that
the remedy for that is to expose bias
where it exists and that's been
something we've done a lot of at
Breitbart and more of since the election
actually we've been
fighting against a lot of the coverage
because we think Trump is a president
who we can hold accountable he's
accountable to his voters is accountable
to the promises he made but he should be
accountable based on policies and
principles not based on the media's
often contrived crises and double
standards they try to catch him on
things they never complained about with
Obama
it's as if they were asleep for eight
years and suddenly they've woken up to
the importance of an independent press
you know well you don't get to complain
about Trump not giving a press
conference when you wanted him to if you
followed Obama all around the golf
course for eight years so that's my path
to Breitbart you know I I like the
company's posture I like a fighting kind
of conservatism I like a fighting kind
of political attitude I don't
necessarily march in lockstep with
everyone else on the site we have lots
of different opinions on the site about
about different issues and same with
Trump I was critical of some of the
things he said some of his policies
during the campaign but I think the
obligation we have to our readers is to
hold him accountable according to the
promises that he made to the people and
and that's the world and right where I
wanted to create he said that democracy
will happen in his words when the
mainstream media filter is no longer
there to prevent it from happening and
we see that democracy as the trust I
don't want to call it a transaction but
the trust that underlies an agreement
between the voters and the president the
president offers certain things to
voters they vote for him they expect he
delivers and and that's what makes
democracy function he's not accountable
to the White House press corps he's
accountable to the American people and
particularly to those who voted for him
so that's the world Breitbart created
and it's the world we're covering and
it's exciting to be part of it the book
was really exciting to write it was a
labor of love didn't take too long
because it was all written on adrenaline
didn't need much sleep just just just
coffee I've since given up coffee by the
way because I was drinking too much of
it during the camp
and decided to take a break and I hope
you won't need coffee to get through
this an exciting read and I think that
people will find it entertaining how
Trump won is the name of the book the
inside story of a revolution Breitbart
news senior editor at large
Joel B [ __ ] is the co-author and
watching book TV on c-span t here's some
books being published this week former
US Marine Sergeant Thomas Brennan and
war photographer Finbar O'Reilly share
their experiences surviving warfare in
shooting ghosts historian Philip Thomas
Tucker explores the impact Alexander
Hamilton had on the Revolutionary War in
Alexander Hamilton's Revolution ESPN
reporters Paula Levine and Mark
Schlabach report on the Baylor
University sexual assault cases in
violated also being published this week
to Syria with love journalist Judith
Newman shares how her son's connection
with an iPhone enlightened her
understanding of his challenges with
autism in on faith and science pulitzer
prize-winning author Edward Larson and
Michael ruse offer their thoughts on the
debate between science and religion
University of California Berkeley
professor urease lestine recalls how the
Russian Revolution led to the death and
imprisonment of over 800 leaders of the
Soviet state in the house of government
and journalist Jeff dim Vicki reports on
how Millennials can impact the future of
climate change in are we screwed look
for these titles in bookstores this
coming week and watch for many of the
authors in the near future on book TV on
c-span too
[Music]
[Music]
good evening welcome to the Atlanta
History Center my name is Kate Wittman
and I'm the VP of public programs
there's a little weird feedback thing
but I think it's good now we are missing
a few people so they will start to to
fill in and please be nice and show them
where there are seats available tonight
is a Nelson lecture and we thank our
sponsor ambassador and mrs. Edward Elson
for supporting this program tonight
Angela Jay Davis just to be really clear
this is Angela J Davis for anyone who is
confused okay is gonna be talking she's
the editor of policing the black man
arrest prosecution and imprisonment
which she will be discussing this
evening she it throughout her career as
a lawyer author and professor Angela J
Davis has dedicated her efforts to
studying and bettering the criminal
justice system in America particularly
as it relates to prosecution allow and
racism within the system tonight's
program is being broadcast for c-span so
this will probably show up in about a
week but that does mean that if you have
a question
you should go to the microphone to ask
it and I forgot to say that so now I'm
gonna go back to her bio but I was like
let me make sure that I get that okay
she Angela Davis is a DC she was a DC
public defender and was the executive
director of the National rainbow
coalition she's the author of arbitrary
justice the power of the American
prosecutor which one the Pauline rule
more award currently Davis is a
professor of law at Washington College
of Law at American University she is the
editor policing the black man please
join me in welcoming Angela J Davis to
the Atlanta History Center
Thank You kay and I want to thank the
Atlanta History Center for having me
this evening and I want to thank all of
you for coming out great to see so many
familiar faces I see people I know and
people I don't know I'm happy to see
everyone and so grateful that so many of
you want to hear about this issue and
talk about this issue so thank you so
much for being here I want to start out
by just talking a little bit about how
this book came about I was approached
about two and a half years ago about
doing a collection of X essays that
would explore and contextualize the many
awful killings of unarmed black men and
boys that have occurred in recent years
and when I was approached and asked I
seized the opportunity because there's
no issue more important to me than the
unfair treatment of black and brown
people in the criminal justice system in
America today in fact it's the issue
that keeps me up at night I thought
about who I would ask to join me in this
project and I decided to reach out to
the authors
lawyers scholars advocates and activists
who've been teaching and writing about
litigating advocating and agitating and
in many instances living this issue and
I was really fortunate that so many of
them said yes so I really want to just
take this opportunity to thank them the
the many authors that contributed to
this project and I'm going to tell you a
little bit about them and about the
essays this evening but the first thing
I want to do is read a brief excerpt
from the books introduction that I hope
will give you a sense of what the book
is about why this book and why now
Michael Brown Eric garner
Tamir rice Walter Scott Freddie gray Sam
DuBose Alton Stirling falando Casteel
and Terrence Crutcher are just some of
the names on a long list of unarmed
black boys and men who were killed by
police officers in recent years although
black men have been the victims of
violence at the hands of the state since
the time of slavery technology and
social media now permit us to literally
bear witness to many of these killings
repeatedly millions of people have
watched the video of a police officer
choking Eric garner to death as he
struggled for air similarly millions
have watched the video of a police
officer shooting Walter Scott in the
back as he ran for his life who can ever
forget the grainy footage of Tamir rice
the twelve-year-old boy who was shot by
a police officer while he played alone
with a toy gun in a park near his home
two videos one from a police helicopter
and another from a police dashboard
camera show Terrence Crutcher walking
away from police officers with his hands
raised high in the air just before he
was shot and killed these images have
evoked feelings of fear sadness and
outrage and serve as a reminder that the
lives of black men and boys continue to
be devalued and destroyed with impunity
at the hands of the state to date not
one of the police officers who killed
these men and boys has been convicted of
a single crime from the arrival of the
first slaves in Jamestown in 1619 to the
lynchings of the 19th and 20th centuries
to the present day black boys and men
have been unlawfully killed by those who
were sworn to uphold the law
and by vigilantes who took the law into
their own hands the National Museum of
african-american history and culture
which opened its doors on September 24th
2016 includes exhibits that tell the
story of many of these killings
yeah these killings are not just a part
of african-american history they have
continued well into the 21st century
almost 400 years after the beginning of
slavery and persist with remarkable
frequency and brutality during a time
when America elected its first
african-american president
many of these race-based killings have
inspired and reinvigorated movements for
change the brutal killing of
fourteen-year-old Emmett Till in
Mississippi in 1955 the murder of civil
rights activists Meckler Evers in 1963
and the assassination of Martin Luther
King in 1968 all serve as markers on the
civil rights movement timeline has it so
many other killings of black men by
white racists each tragic killing
sparked nationwide protests and renewed
activism in the struggle for civil
rights and racial justice in the United
States the killing of 17 year old
Trayvon Martin in 2012 was a pivotal
marker of racial violence against black
men in the 21st century Martin was
killed by George Zimmerman a white man
who called the police when he saw Martin
walking in his neighborhood Zimmerman a
member of a neighborhood crime watch
group reported to the police that Martin
loved suspicious and that he looked like
he was quote up to no good or on drugs
or something
unquote ignoring the dispatchers warning
that he should not follow Martin
Zimmerman ultimately shot and killed him
Martin was unarmed and was on his way
back to his father's house after buying
snacks at a local convenience store
initially Zimmerman was not even charged
with a crime but after nationwide
protests he was charged with Martin's
murder a jury ultimately acquitted him
the killing of Trayvon Martin the
initial failure of the prosecutor to
charges mm with a crime and Zimmerman's
ultimate acquittal captured the
attention of the nation President Obama
even weighed in stating quote Trayvon
Martin could have been me 35 years ago
unquote Martin's killing also inspired
the phrase black lives matter
the phrase trended on Twitter and all
forms of social media
and was displayed on posters carried in
protests after Martin's killing and
after every killing of a black man or
woman by a police officer from that day
forward black lives matter ultimately
became a social justice movement with
chapters throughout the United States
and Canada many unarmed black men and
boys have been killed since Trayvon
Martin's tragic death five years ago
many of the killings occurred after
police officers arguably engaged in
racial profiling stopping and harassing
these men for no explainable reason
other than the color of their skin in
all of the cases where black men were
shot and killed the officers claimed
they had felt that they felt threatened
even though the men were unarmed and
often running away or retreating in
almost all of the cases the police
officers were never arrested or charged
with a crime the tragic killings of
Trayvon Martin Michael Brown Eric garner
Walter Scott Tamir rice Freddie gray and
others served as the catalyst for this
anthology but these killings also
inspire the contributing authors to
think about all of the ways that black
men are policed in the broad sense of
the word heavily and harshly at every
step of the criminal process in fact
black men are policed and treated worse
than their similarly situated white
counterparts at every step of the
criminal justice system from arrest
through sentencing these unwarranted
disparities exist whether black men are
charged with crimes or are victims of
crime police officers stop search and
arrest black men far more frequently
than white men engaged in the same
behavior prosecutors charge black men
more frequently and with more serious
crimes than white men who engage in the
same behavior and there are
disproportionate numbers of black men in
the nation's prisons and jails criminal
defendants regardless of their race are
punished less harshly when their victims
are black men this anthology explores
and explains the
leasing of black men from slavery to the
present day and at every stage of the
criminal process and beyond now many
people have asked why black men why are
you focusing on black men aren't there
other people in the criminal justice
system were treated not as not well or
treated poorly and the answer to that is
yes so how would I answer that question
black men are not the only people of
color to be treated worse than their
similarly situated white counterparts at
every step of the criminal process black
women Latina women Latino men Native
Americans and other people of color also
experience violence at the hands of the
state and discriminatory treatment in
the criminal justice system as do people
who are gay lesbian and or transgender
this book's focus on black men in no way
trivializes the experiences of all
people who face these harms while
acknowledging that other groups have
been and continue to be oppressed and
discriminated against this books this
book focuses on black men in many ways
the experience of black men in the
criminal justice system is unique the
most noticeable difference is that they
are impacted more adversely than any
other demographic in the United States
at every step of the process black boys
are disproportionately arrested and
detained black boys are more likely to
be referred to the juvenile justice
system than any other children over half
of the students arrested at school in
the United States and refer to the
juvenile justice system are black and
Hispanic and while black students
represent only 16% of students
enrollment they represent 27% of
students referred to law enforcement and
31 percent of students subjected to
school arrests black male students alone
make up 18% of all referrals and arrests
black men are disproportionately
arrested
african-americans are 2.5 times more
likely to be arrested than whites and 49
percent of black men almost have can
expect to be arrested at least once
by age 23 black men are more likely to
be killed or injured during a police
encounter while while more whites are
killed by law enforcement than people of
color African Americans are killed at a
disproportionate rate in fact black men
are 21 times more likely to be killed by
police than white men black men are
disproportionately imprisoned and
receive longer sentences African
Americans make up approximately 35% of
the prison population in the United
States 35% and by the end of 2015 black
men constituted 34 percent of the
American prison population in 2015 5165
in 100,000 black men ages 25 to 29 were
imprisoned as compared to 2000 165
Hispanic men and 920 one white men of
the same age remarkably the number of
black men in prison or jail on probation
or on parole by the end of 2009 roughly
equaled the number enslaved in 1850 one
in three black men born in 2001 one and
three can expect to be incarcerated in
his lifetime blacks are also
disproportionately sentenced to death as
of 2014 the national death row
population is apart was approximately
42% black while the overall black
population is only thirteen point six
percent so for all of those reasons this
anthology focuses on the plight of black
men and boys the extraordinarily
disproportionate mistreatment of black
boys and men at every step of the
criminal process is explored in depth in
this book as the essays make clear the
issues and problems are complex as are
the solutions the authors that I invited
to join me in this project our scholars
lawyers and activists who have studied
and in
instances personally experienced the
phenomenon about which they write so in
their essays they examine and explain
the policing of black men I want to tell
you a little bit about the essays and
then I want to talk about my own essay
my own contribution to the book which is
about the prosecution of black men and
talk to you about why I think that issue
is so important so just briefly I'll
tell you the titles and hopefully they
will inspire you to want to pick up the
book and read it the first essay is
called a presumption of guilt the legacy
of America's history of racial injustice
and it was written by Bryan Stevenson
the second essay is the endurance of
racial disparity in the criminal justice
system by Marc Maurer it's the head of
the Sentencing Project and in DC I
should say Bryan steals and I heard some
of you comment so you know who he is
remarkable hero of mine who runs equal
justice initiative the third essay is
called boys to men the role of policing
and the socialization of black boys
written by Professor Kristen Henning of
Georgetown and this I will tell you all
this that this essay almost didn't make
it to the book because I was so focused
on black men and then after talking to
Chris is one of the nation's top leading
experts on the juvenile justice system I
realized wow of course we have to talk
about black boys and that chapter is
remarkable because actually black boys
are treated worse in the system than
black men and so that that essay is
pretty revealing the next one is called
racial profiling the law the policy and
the practice written by Professor Rene
McDonald Hutchins of the University of
Maryland racial profiling is how so many
of these killings start and it explains
it the next chapter is black men and the
police making implicit bias explicit I
don't know many of you may have heard
about implicit bias it's a theme that
goes through all of these essays and is
that the root of so many of these
killings and I'll talk a bit about that
tonight it was written by Professor
Catherine Russell Brown the University
of Florida the next chapter is called
policing a model for the 21st century by
professors Tracy Mears
Tom Tyler professor Mears served on
President Obama's Task Force on policing
in the 21st century the next chapter is
my own chapter it's called the
prosecution of black man I'm going to
talk about that a little bit tonight
then the grand jury and police violence
against black men by Professor Roger
Fairfax a lot of people were introduced
to the grand jury after Ferguson when
they realized that the police officer
wouldn't be indicted so professor
Fairfax explains the whole history of
the grand jury and reveals some things
that will probably be very surprising to
many of you who witnessed what happened
with a lot of these police officers very
different from for ordinary citizens
with the grand jury the next chapter is
called elected prosecutors and police
accountability by Professor Ron right I
focus a lot on electing good progressive
prosecutors and that chapter will be
revealing when it talks about how
prosecutors are elected and the next
chapter is called do black lives matter
to the courts and it was written by
sherrilyn Ifill who was the director
counsel of the n-double a-c-p Legal
Defense and Educational Fund and also by
Jim Healey who co-authored the chapter
with her she's a staff attorney there
talks about the law and the history of
the law and will reveal a lot about why
it's so difficult while the courts are
not exactly friendly to claims of
discrimination anymore and many other
issues and the final chapter is called
poverty violence and black incarceration
by Jeremy Travis and Bruce Western so
those are the essays and I want to spend
the remainder of my time before opening
it up for questions talking about my own
contribution to the volume which is
called the prosecution of black men and
also if there's time a little bit about
these killings and you know how is it
why is it how could it be that these
police officers have not been held
accountable I think that's a question I
get and I'm not sure I know the answer
but would like to explore and talk about
what I think some of the issues are but
a little bit about my chapter I and Kate
mentioned that I've spent a lot of my
time writing about prosecutors and I
have
and the reason for that is that
prosecutors are actually the most
powerful officials in our criminal
justice system there's always been a lot
of focus on police officers and rightly
so we know there should be a focus given
all that has been going on and by the
way I you know just to stress and I
mentioned this before the killings of
black men didn't start with Trayvon
Martin these this has been going on
since since slavery and so Bryan
Stevenson's chapter lays that out and
explains that so well but and it's of
course there should be a focus on police
officers police officers have a
tremendous amount of power and
discretion on the street to stop people
to search them and the law makes it very
easy for them to do that but I think
people should focus also on prosecutors
and I don't think people have been
focusing on them a lot they are the most
powerful officials in our criminal
justice system police officers
absolutely have a lot of power to stop
people on the street search them frisk
them arrest them but police officers can
only bring people to the courthouse door
it is the prosecutor who decides whether
they remain entrenched in the system and
and end up with a criminal record and
all of that the prosecutor has so much
to do with that and that is because of
the two powers they have the charging
decision and the plea bargaining
decision those two decisions made by
prosecutors almost predetermine the
outcome of criminal cases and why do I
say that well if a police officer
arrests a person on the street they can
only recommend charges to the prosecutor
they don't decide whether the person is
in the criminal justice system they can
bring a case to the prosecutor and the
prosecutor can decide to take it you
know and prosecute the case or they can
dismiss it it's totally up to the
prosecutor even if there's probable
cause to believe the person committed
the offense and that's the standard the
very low standard of probable cause is
what the standard is for charging a
person more probable than not very easy
to show that much lower than the much
higher proof beyond a reasonable doubt
that they need to convict so a
prosecutor can just
to charge a person at that point or they
can decide not to charge the person it's
totally within their discretion and they
are accountable to no one but the chief
prosecutor of that office right and that
decision is made behind closed doors
right that this is not a public decision
prosecutors don't tell the make a public
announcement I'm charging this person
and I'm not charging that person and
here's why they're not required to do
that and they don't do that they make
those decisions behind closed doors so
you can see when there's that much
discretion and power that that's where
disparities can come in and where they
do right if a prosecutor you know can
see one kid brought in let's say he's
arrested with five bags of cocaine
prosecutors got a lot of options there
the police officer might say well he's
he's got five bags of cocaine why don't
you charge him with possession with
intent to distribute cocaine which is a
felony offense that in most states
carries a mandatory minimum sentence of
five ten sometimes more years mandatory
minimum meaning that if the person is
convicted they must serve all of that
time no matter what so the prosecutor
facing looking at a potential defendant
with five bags of cocaine can charge
five counts can charge five counts of
possession with intent to distribute
charge the felony but they also can just
simply charge the misdemeanor possession
even though they may have the evidence
for the felony they can see I think I'll
just charge the misdemeanor or they can
just dismiss it and say I'm not charging
at all they have the discretion to do
any of those things and they do not have
to explain those decisions to a judge or
anyone else it's made behind closed
doors the chief prosecutor is the only
person who was in charge of that that's
a tremendous amount of power if you
think about it right because the one kid
comes in and he sees one kid says well
it you know I remember when I was back
in college I used to sell a little dope
youthful indiscretion
I've turned out all right and that kid
you know this kid over here looks like
you know a kid who looks a certain way
reminds me of me when I was young and
he's got a future and I don't want to
ruin that future by with a criminal
record someone will let this slide where
the another kid comes in looking very
different from a very different
neighborhood right and he's
automatically maybe he'll charge him
with the felony that's a tremendous
amount of power and the thing about it
is it's complicated because I'm not
saying that that prosecutors saying you
know that's a witch rich white kid I'm
gonna give him a break that's a poor
black kid I'm not they may not even be
consciously thinking that way and that's
when this thing called implicit bias
comes in right these unconscious
feelings and views that we all every one
of us in this room of all races and
genders have right the unconscious views
that we all have based on negative
stereotypes that we pick up in society
around us and the media everywhere right
could be based on race or gender or skin
color or hair or body size we're not
even aware we have those biases it's
that thing that makes some people when a
black man walks on the elevator they
don't even realize that bodies moving
over to the corner right and not just
white folks by the way right I don't
know if anybody remembers I know this
it's on c-span Reverend Jackson don't be
mad at me but I don't know if you all
remember years ago when Reverend Jackson
was waters came out that he was walking
down the street in Washington DC and he
said he looked behind him and was
relieved to see that it was a white man
Reverend Jackson who I used to work for
who I love but my point is that all of
us carry these implements the problem is
that when when people have tremendous
power in the criminal justice system and
they are making decisions that are
impacted by that implicit bias that's
that's a dangerous thing right because
you have someone's life and liberty in
your hand
and you're being influenced by your
unconscious fuse you're not even
realizing what you're doing but yet it's
happening right and the fact that it's
unintentional doesn't mean it's okay
the fact that it's unintentional doesn't
mean that the result is going to be
different it's still wrong if someone is
treated unfairly if these two young men
similarly situated right both of them
charged with the same thing maybe
neither one of them had a record goes
that's one of the things that
prosecutors take into account right or
maybe the black kid did have an arrest
record but guess what none of those
cases actually he wasn't convicted why
maybe because they were the result of
racial profiling and there wasn't a case
there so there's all there's all kinds
of complicated things that go into that
charging decision same thing with plea
bargaining so if you all watch that show
well there are many Law & Order shows I
guess the best if you watch any of the
many Law & Order so do you think all of
these trials are going on not so in the
criminal justice system they're not a
lot of trials going on there a lot of
guilty pleas going on 95% of all
criminal cases are resolved by way of a
guilty plea 95% only 5% of criminal
cases actually go to trial with a jury
and all that and that process the plea
bargaining process is again totally
controlled by prosecutors so how does it
work
prosecutor says okay I'm going to charge
you with five counts of burglary me and
that's the other thing there's just a
phenomenon of overcharging they may not
even be sure they can prove all of those
burglaries beyond a reasonable doubt but
they sure can't charge them because all
they have to do to charge them is to
show probable cause like more likely
than not so they pile on all these
charges and it gives them an advantage
at the plea bargaining stage all right
you're facing let's make it a harder
case let's say it's drugs again with
five mandatory minimum charges you're
looking at 50 years on the bottom
meaning like you're going to have if
you're convicted after trial you're
gonna be you're gonna have to serve 50
years before you see the light of day
tell you what says the prosecutor I'll
make you
I will allow you to plead to one of
these men to ten-year mandatory minimum
offenses and I'll dismiss the other four
sounds like a good deal right you can
see how even an innocent person will
plead guilty because going to trial is
risky business even if you're innocent
you could be found guilty and so many
poor people most of the people come with
justice some are poor people many of
them have overworked public defenders of
court-appointed attorneys many who are
good lawyers but don't have the
resources to reinvestigate the cases to
find a defense right so anything could
happen in trial so even an innocent
person under those circumstances might
be compelled to feel like they should
plead guilty and many people so many
people do 95% and I'm not saying plea
bargaining is a bad thing if it were
fair it would be fine
by that I mean this a lot of times these
plea offers are made like a prosecutor
can come up to the defense attorney and
say I tell you what you know I'll give
you a guy deal but it expires at 5
o'clock to the heat it takes agrees to
take the plea or it's off the table and
the defense attorney might say well wait
a minute I have an ethical duty to
investigate these charges to find out
whether my client has a defense how can
I advise my client to do this and I
don't even know and too bad and that's
not illegal actually folks in our
criminal justice system that's not the
way justice is supposed to work but it
goes on every day in courtrooms across
the country where a defense attorney is
going to the client saying look I don't
know you may have a defense but they're
making this offer you know and just the
decision is up to the client that's not
the way justice is supposed to look now
if the plea bargaining process worked in
a way that the prosecutor says here's my
file here's all the evidence I have
against you here's everything I know
about the case and I'm gonna give you
time to investigate and then you let me
know whether you want to take the plea
that happens sometimes I'm not saying
all prosecutors act the way that I
mentioned before but many of them do
that is the system that we have in a lot
of jurisdictions where there's a lot of
press
everybody to move the cases along clear
the calendar judges love please I
apologize if there any judges and in the
audience
judges love please because please only
take a few minutes trials take sometimes
days and they've got to move that
calendar right but there's a human being
behind all of them right so you can see
why I think prosecutors are the most
powerful individuals in the criminal
justice system and I could go on and on
interest of time I won't but I will say
this one more thing about prosecutors
you know the problem is and I talked to
some of my prosecutor friends and they
say look and because I say to them you
know you guys make these decisions
behind closed doors you're not
accountable to the public people don't
know what you're doing there are racial
disparities that you're causing maybe
not intentionally but you are and they
will say well look if my constituents
don't like me they can just vote me out
and I say well well somebody thinks
that's funny in theory right we live in
a democracy and you know we hold those
accountable to whom we grant power and
the prosecutors are the most powerful
democracy is all about transparency and
there is no transparency in the in the
prosecution function when it comes to
charging and plea bargaining those
decisions as I said are made behind
closed doors so most state and local
prosecutors and I should say that there
are federal prosecutors those are the US
Attorney's that are over the federal
districts and then there are state and
local prosecutors only about 10% of all
criminal cases are handled on the
federal level only 10% 90% of all
criminal cases are handled on the state
and local level so there are thousands
of state's attorneys District Attorney's
they'll call different things in
different jurisdictions out there and
they're elected there are only five
jurisdictions four states in the
District of Columbia do not have elected
prosecutors they have another process
but all the rest of them they're elected
they run for office and it's a very
imperfect system of accountability
because it
writes chapter you'll read about how
many prosecutors they serve for decades
run unopposed people go to the ballot
box in an election year and sometimes
there's only one name there because
people don't challenge them and when
they do try to challenge an incumbent
it's almost impossible to unseat them
and when they run for office they're not
talking about the stuff I'm talking
about here today right they're not
saying to their constituents they're not
saying hear my plea bargaining policies
and hear my charging policies and here's
what I'm doing about racial disparities
and the criminal justice is my dad if
you've heard any DA's run on that
they've in the past anyway and still so
in most jurisdictions they run on I'm
tough on crime and if they have an
opponent they'll say I'm tougher on
crime and they don't really talk about
what they do these really important
decisions that they're making behind
closed doors and so that's why it's so
important that we all educate ourselves
so we can ask the hard questions I bet
if you would go to a forum put on by a
prosecutor and raise your hand and say
what are your charging and plea
bargaining policies they would faint
right their payment and I urge you to do
that you should ask that question right
but I say to you it's really important
to pay attention to your district
attorney races it's really important for
good people who care about justice in
the criminal justice system to run for
office and I'm happy to say in 2060 a
number of prosecutors were challenged
around the country and we're unseated
not that many but some and a lot of
attention has been paid to them Kim Fox
in Chicago Aramis Ayana in Orlando
Florida and I could go on and on so
there is a movement I think of people
paying more attention to prosecutors and
what they do and I'm happy to hear that
I think it's really important that that
we pay attention to that and I just want
to close again with some some statistics
and then open it up for questions you
know the United States criminal justice
system is the largest in the world at
the end of 2011 approximately 7mm
individuals who are under some form of
correctional control in the United
States including 2.2 million
incarcerated in federal state or local
prisons and jails the United States has
the highest incarceration rate in the
world
dwarf in the rate of nearly every other
nation racial minorities are more likely
than white Americans to be arrested once
arrested they're more likely to be
convicted once convicted they are more
likely to face stiff sentences African
American males are six times more likely
to be incarcerated than white males then
they're similarly situated white
counterparts and 2.5 times more likely
than Hispanic males if the current
trends continue one of every three black
American males born to born today can
expect to go to prison in his lifetime
as can one of every six latino males as
compared to one of every 17 white males
so we have a problem in this country
today right it's not it's not a badge of
honor to be number one and incarceration
in the world it's a badge of shame right
why is it that we're so different from
every other country where why are we
doing this so differently and why do we
have these horrible racial disparities
as I've tried to explain tonight
it's complicated there are a lot of
complex reasons why but at the end of
the day it's an unjust and unfair system
and we all have to to fight to change it
so thank you for hearing me out not be
happy
after reminder comes with the microphone
so it doesn't have carrots uh for about
two Davidson's talking I've often found
that the saddest picture that I've seen
during the civil rights movement and I
wasn't the civil rights movement it's
men carrying signs saying I am a man has
so painful to watch that I believe that
in police involved shootings the person
is not seen as human and and is fear
that once whether running away where the
nude whether with without without a
weapon
responsibility is it to change that
perception it's not a training issue
it's not a culture a police issue
what can fix it because that to be so
central that if you will shoot someone
who's nude has happened in our in our
state someone who's running like water's
coming from unarmed people for Linda
Castillo I mean it's just it's so
painful to see that and then you look at
how a Dylan roof was treated and he
killed ninety four sometimes well whose
job is that whose responsibility is it
to is to fix it so that when you see
this person unarmed or not this
african-american male is a human being
and it then deserves respected yes thank
you so much for that very insightful
question and statement I mean what you
said you knew this already that what you
just said is in a lot of the essays
actually yeah you know it's really scary
and sad and depressing that for black
men and boys their very existence right
they can be doing nothing standing on
the street corner talking just being
right just living create suspicion in
the minds of certain people they see
black and they see criminal or not human
you just said that and that's so true in
several of the chapters the chapter on
implicit bias christenings chapter which
is by Katherine Russell Brown
christenings chapter on black boys they
discuss these studies that are really
quite shocking that show you know
particularly police officers to try to
gage whether they have this implicit
bias that I talked about before
will they'll show them these images
black boys and they repeatedly
overestimate the age and size of black
boys always seeing them as older and
larger than they really are because of
this bias immediately that's what they
see even when it's out there some of the
police studies that were done in the
chapter about implicit bias where they
would ask police officers they show us
them these images very quickly and ask
them to respond when should they shoot
or not shoot they would see weapons in
the hands of unarmed black men and not
see them in the hands of white men who
were armed because of this implicit bias
these studies show this right so you
know it's an incredible burden to put on
a black boy or a man quite frankly to
say you know what at the certain way you
know everybody a lot of people and have
given their sons and daughters probably
the talk don't talk back to police
officers put your hands on the wheel
don't say the thing is scary and
maddening and infuriating is that we saw
in a lot of these videotapes right if I
believe it was falando Castillo's case
you know all we saw even in the other
case Tamir rice was playing who have a
gun I mean they weren't doing anything
wrong so is this you know telling folks
act a certain way is not going to save
you all the time and that's what scare
say your question what can we do about
you said it's not a question of training
well actually some of our scholarship
think that that is a big part of it
because there is something called
implicit bias training I know people
hear about the diversity training that I
start to roll I get it because a lot of
the training is like not really you know
but there is really good training around
implicit bias that's why Katherine
Russell's Brown's chapter is called
making implicit bias explicit because
what the studies show is that when you
make people aware of their implicit
biases that's the first step in getting
rid of it
so there's actually very good implicit
bias training out here the few people
that are doing it I recently went to a
sort of a conference on this in
Washington DC where they brought
together many different people in the
criminal justice system parole folks
probation judges and the woman who was
doing the training it there's a specific
training to try to root out there's a
judge several judges now who are giving
instructions to jurors about implicit
bias to make them aware of it before
they make decision so I do think
training is a big part of it you know at
least a step anyway I'll stop there
we're gonna go to this side now I'm an
elderly white woman and I thought I
didn't have any bias but I've read this
book and I found that I have implicit
inherited bias from slavery